Frederick Douglas had this great quote, "I
shall always unite with those who do good,
but I shall not unite with those who do wrong."
I wish this person could be alive today to
be an example of what kids can be and do.
If they have the drive to conceive of a dream
and the guts and the strength and the motivation
to achieve that dream, we want to be part
of the resources that help them receive that
dream.
And that's my biggest hope.
I think that to invest in kids that can become
great from Hillsdale is really to invest in
the future of our country.
You know, my grandparents were tremendously
philanthropic.
They talked about the importance of helping
others that can't otherwise afford to do things
that are important.
The emphasis in my father's teaching was invest
in other people.
Don't just keep it all for yourself.
My specialty is working with terminally ill
adults and children in grief therapy.
I actually was led to that because when I
was thirteen years old, I was diagnosed with
Muscular dystrophy.
It was a misdiagnosis.
I was in a wheelchair and effectively blind
because my muscles were not strong enough
to see straight forward.
Came to Detroit and there it was found that
I was misdiagnosed.
So I felt I had gotten my life back and I
am confident that that had a great deal of
influence on my direction.
I love my private practice.
People ask me how can I hold somebody in my
arms when they die, and say, I could never
do that.
I could never be an accountant.
I do believe my experiences as a child--understanding
that I was not going to be living very long--has
really helped me to become very comfortable
helping others to die.
Into Michigan, when I had my first call from
McCormick Theological Seminary.
I met Bonnie there and she claims that I promised
her a ticket to heaven.
In truth, I'm the one who got that ticket,
I think, because we've been married thirty-four
years, and I'm married to my best friend and
I'm still stupidly in love with her, so it's
cool.
Bonnie is an alum, our daughter Hillary went
to Hillsdale, too.
She got a degree in psychology and now she
is working in philanthropic work as well.
The thing that makes Hillsdale Hillsdale are
the students that aspire to go there and to
do great things.
That's really what our interest has been.
Hopefully, to support students, especially
those who otherwise couldn't afford to go
there.
I love Hillsdale College.
I think that school is one of the most amazing
resources in America.
I've always told my wife, "Doggone it, I wish
I had graduated from this school."